13 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
feel on the App Store or Google Play
isolation exercises can increase in
muscle mass that means you can also
increase the size of your breasts
naturally by doing targeted chess
exercises
now if done regularly this can result in
fuller firmer looking breasts and it can
also enhance your cleavage our pact or
our chest muscles can be divided into
the upper mid and also lower chest
ladies you should be focusing on upper
chest exercises to give your bust that
extra lift and to prevent sagginess I'm
gonna share with you my favorite upper
chest exercises for each workout if you
want to complete between 12 to 15
repetitions and aim for 4 sets let's get
started let's start with the first
superset which will be smith machine
incline chest press with low cable fly
to performed incline chest press you
want position the bench to a 45 degree
angle with the bar position directly
under your upper chest
Griffin bar firmly and sugar with
distance now slowly lower the bar at a
three-count temple until it is close to
your upper chest and engage the upper
chest muscles to drive the bar up do not
rush through the workout I prefer to use
the smith machine because this offers me
better stability especially if i want to
lift heavier now let's superset that
with low cable fly when you do this
workout you want to imagine your drawing
and a shape
so spread your arms slightly away from
your sights with the elbows slightly
bent drive the cables upward until they
are parallel or just above the eye line
slowly release in a controlled manner
and repeat you want to avoid swinging
your entire body or use momentum to
drive the cables up the only part that
should be moving are your arms look
straight ahead throughout the workout as
this will help you to keep your posture
upright and chest open this is not an
easy workout hence your only need to
lift really light
now repeat both exercises back to back
for 4 rounds before moving on to the
next superset the next superset will be
incline dumbbell chest press with
incline dumbbell fly once again keep the
bench to a 45 degree angle plant your
feet firmly on the ground and keep your
chest up engage the chest as you drive
both dumbbells straight up in line with
the upper chest have good control as you
lower the dumbbells keeping your arms in
a 90 degree angle avoid pushing the
dundas forward as this could strain your
shoulders and engage to the wrong
muscles so look straight up and this
will help to keep the dumbbells in line
with the upper chest let's super set
this with incline dumbbell fly keeping
yourself in the same position start with
the dumbbells up palms facing each other
slowly spread your arms out to the side
until they are parallel with your
shoulders squeeze your upper chest and
drive the dumbbells back up to the
ceiling
make sure to keep your elbows soft and
slightly bent throughout the workout
repeat both exercises back to back for
another 4 sets
now that you've completed a total of two
super sets and four exercises we want to
end this with a killer workout which
will be declined push-ups your goal is
to complete as many repetitions as
possible within 45 seconds with a 15
second rest interval and you want to
complete a total of 4 sets the aim is to
train until failure these are my
favorite upper chest exercises which I
do in the gym on a weekly basis do this
regularly and it will give you fuller
and firmer breasts naturally do you
enjoy this gym workout if you do let me
know in the comments below and also let
me know what videos do you want to watch
be sure to give this video a thumbs up
subscribe to my youtube channel and
check out more workout videos on my
channel
all the best